what up yo
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
for today june 8 20 21 as always
click that subscribe button tap that
notification bell
share our videos and note mentally
that we now clip the direct messages
usually into two or three segments that
we put out
for smaller bytes throughout the day so
you can always go to youtube.com
reubenreport and see what's what and of
course we
repost everything ad free and without
algorithmic manipulation
at reubenreport.locals.com i'm feeling
good today i've got some
stories that are gonna enlighten you and
uh and i think as i said yesterday at
the close of the show
i think there's some good trends and i'm
gonna focus on those trends
first off uh today we're going to be
discussing kamala harris who is
the vice president of the united states
this is a woman who was polling at
zero percent within her own party when
she stepped out of the presidential race
but then joe biden chose her to be his
running mate
why i have no idea i wouldn't want to
speculate
well she is in guatemala and she's
warning people
not to come to our border sounds very
trumpian
very bizarre we're going to show you
some video on that then on the good news
that i was just alluding to
uh remember barack obama he was the
two-term president a while back before
the orange guy
uh well obama is now being trotted out
there to do interviews
to sort of attack the republicans and
kind of attack white people and they got
him to comment
on critical race theory and the fact
even that this interview happened even
that he brought
this topic up i think shows you that
we're kind of winning because now
they're busting out
the old all-stars it's like it's like
old-timers game
and they're bringing out the old guys
for the greatest hits and i think it
shows you that we're actually making
some headway here so we'll talk about
that
and then finally you may remember this
new york times
journalist by the name of mara gay we
talked about her a couple weeks ago
because
she interviewed andrew yang for the new
york times and she
basically called me a white supremacist
she said that i regularly host
white supremacists on the dave rubin
show which isn't even the name of this
show
we tried to get a retraction and a
correction but they don't do that at the
new york times because it's not a place
journalism
well anyway she was on msnbc i think it
was this morning
and she was triggered she was triggered
because you're not going to believe this
she was out in long island
i'm from long island i know about long
island it is the it is the place of
bagels and pizza
okay a lot of carbs on long island she
was out on long island and she saw
people
in pickup trucks they had american flags
okay they were waving around american
flags
driving down the l.i.e the long island
expressway probably heading out to the
hamptons
okay and they had american flags and it
just freaked her out
we'll talk about all of that and more
just a second
but i want to talk to you guys right now
about
bonner private wine you ever go out to a
bbq joint i was actually just that one
in austin texas a couple days ago
and the next day you're still digesting
all the meat you know that feeling well
here's a tip
drink some red wine guys not only does
it taste great but red wine actually
makes you digest
meat more effectively in fact according
to some studies it even makes red meat
healthier
but not all red wines are equal you
don't want to ma you don't want some
mass-market red wine full of chemicals
and pesticides
instead you need to check out the
extreme altitude malbec from argentina
extreme altitude means grapes grown at
around 9000 feet
they're fed off pure snow melt no excess
chemicals
with notes of blackberry leather smoke
and dark cherry this wine is delicious
as you know i'm doing the tri-tips
lately and i've been busting out the
malbecs
the guys over at freethinkerwine.com are
telling me they just got another special
shipment of these wines in including one
from the third
highest vineyard in the world my
audience can get 50
off if you go there today just visit
freethinkerwine.com that's a website
they sent out
set up just for us that's
freethinkerwine.com and now back to me
all right we got a lot to get to and i'm
feeling good here we go so first off
kamala harris she's down
in guatemala and uh she don't want
people coming to the u.s
very bizarre position for a democrat to
take especially knowing that
we've got video of you when you were
running for president kamala and we're
going to get to that
in just a sec but here's kamala
yesterday just quickly put a button
okay do you have any plans to visit the
border
at some point you know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this whole
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the borders
we're back oh we're back okay sorry i
did the clips backwards there so that's
obviously her talking to lester holt
and she's implying that she's been to
the border he's like no you haven't been
to the border and she's like oh well
we're going also this way she conflates
our southern border
with europe meaning she hasn't gone
there either it's like well people
aren't just walking across that atlantic
ocean thing
and just walking into our country we
know that now thousands of people are
doing this and that our border
facilities
are overrun and there are kids in cages
we used to care about that it was like
auschwitz now we don't really care aoc
is pretty quiet on all that stuff
but now let's throw to this video of
kamala in guatemala
with a message for people who want to
come to the united states
i want to be clear to folks in this
region who are thinking about
making that dangerous trek
to the united states mexico border
do not come do not come
we have always presented ourselves as
being a nation of
strength with strong arms that when
people are fleeing harm
we will embrace them but look at what
has happened with this administration
there are children who are fleeing
murder capitals of
the world let's be clear about this
imagine a mother who makes a decision
to pay a coyote to
transport her child across the entire
country of mexico
facing unknown peril
she does that because she believes for
that child to stay
where they are is worse okay so what we
did there was
juxtapose two videos the first one of
course was her yesterday in guatemala
where she's basically telling people not
to come and nothing good is going to
happen here in the u.s
the other one was her as a candidate and
again she pulled at zero when she
dropped out
of the presidential race and at that
point of course she's telling people
yeah you can come and we've got to take
care of people and everything else now i
get it politicians all lie
republicans lie too conservatives lie
too
but the difference here is that for four
years
we were told what a racist and a bigot
and a white supremacist donald trump
was right he wanted to build a wall he
didn't want immigrants to come here
illegally he would often talk about how
he was pro-immigrant and actually wanted
them to come
legally just not illegally so it's a
little
extra odd the hypocrisy when it's a
democrat who is just calling the other
guy
racist is now just repeating the same
exact
things that donald trump has been saying
for a long time and you're not going to
believe it we've got receipts
here's donald trump on immigration and
they've got to stop
letting people come in illegally i love
people coming into the country legally
that's fine
but we have to stop illegal immigration
in this country
we have people coming into the country
and i'm not talking mexico i'm talking
from all over the world
we have no idea where they came from who
they
are what they did
you see you see what just happened there
that's donald trump
in the midst of his presidency i think
that's about two years in saying the
same thing that he said for
all the four years which is i'm not
anti-immigrant but i'm anti-illegal
immigrant we got to know where these
people are coming from what they're
doing blah blah blah blah blah
and that's what they were calling him
racist for for four years he was a
racist white supremacist
kamala harris is now saying the exact
same thing and dare
dare i give a o freaking frequency
credit but aoc knows that kamala
is a hypocrite here's what aoc tweeted
to kamala this is disappointing to see
first seeking asylum at any u.s border
is a hundred percent legal method of
arrival
second the u.s spent decades
contributing to regime change and
destabilization in latin america we
can't help set someone
someone's house on fire and then blame
them for fleeing so i want to put aside
the secondary part there because of
course
aoc always wants to figure out a way to
blame the united states for everything
right no matter what happens in the
world
aoc and ilhan omar and rashida talib and
the hamas caucus they want to figure out
a way to always blame us
at the same time also telling us how you
know the united states is
racist we're systemically racist we're
evil and patriarchal and capitalism is
wrong and all of those things
but we should also let everyone in
because i guess the horrors that we have
pale into the pale in comparison to the
horrors that they've got
uh but i sort of like the fact that at
least she was somewhat
calling out the hypocrisy of kamala
harris there
and again when we talk about the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy thing it goes
both ways politicians are hypocrites
politicians need power they say whatever
they can to get into power
but this shows you why the false cries
of racism and bigotry that have
basically been
set as the norm in politics if you don't
like what someone says
you you falsely call them a bigot or a
racist
or a homophobe or whatever it is it
shows you how absolutely dangerous it is
because trump
was not a bigot and not a racist and if
you think that he was
then you basically think that kamala
harris is a bigot and a racist
now every single country and this is
exactly what i said for all the years
that trump was president and i said it
for years that obama was president
before that
every single country has a duty and a
right
to defend its borders as it sees fit
every nation
is allowed to let in people or not let
in people
you don't want nations that don't let
people out that's where it starts
getting dangerous that's kind of like
the
the germany you know nazi thing that's
kind of like north korea now you don't
want to trap
people here you want freedom of movement
but every country can decide how many
people
they want to let in or if you have to
have relatives that are already in the
country or if you have to have a job
ready for you we've got so many problems
here uh
homelessness economy drug use
a lot of stuff's going on in america
right now it would be okay if in my
humble opinion if we were like uh you
know we're actually not gonna let anyone
in for a little while we gotta sort
things
out you know what i mean like if your
whole house is on fire you don't welcome
everybody in at the exact same time if
we just took a pause
and we're like boy we have to figure
some of this stuff out because we've got
real
major problems here and i think there
was a pandemic or something for a year
and a half and that seems to be wrapping
up now
now that it's no longer politically
expedient for the powers that be
um so i think i think you get the point
here either kamala harris owes
donald trump an apology or she's just
come out as a racist i
can only see those as the two options
it's very bizarre
or could it possibly be that donald
trump was never a racist in the first
place and they've just
used the worst sort of political attacks
to attain power could that be could i be
so cynical as to think such a thing
well think about it uh anyway let's talk
about barack obama he was the two-term
president before
the orange guy and you know he's been
somewhat
quiet over the years you know he chimed
in every now and again
uh during the trump presidency but
actually not too much and
in my opinion that's what a good
president should do george w bush
has been very quiet post-presidency you
know they've worked on things there were
remember
during some of the hurricanes we had
bill clinton they trotted him out with
george
w and and you know they can work on sort
of humanitarian things together but
personally i think it's pretty good
when a president basically says hey i
did my thing and now i'm going to sort
of
back out or you could be a statesman in
like a bigger sense without getting lost
in the mire and muck
of politics uh and obama's actually been
pretty decent about it not great and
it's he's come out a little bit more
lately
anyway he just did an interview and you
need to take a look at this because
uh he's going to blame a lot of stuff on
you're not going to believe it the
right-wingers and the media
of course you know that right-wing media
machine it's so ubiquitous and
everywhere because there's no left-wing
media machine right
most of culture isn't left-wing pushing
all this nonsense on us
but then he really makes the point of
you know
it's those racist white people that
really have the problems but don't take
my words for it
barack obama i also think that there are
certain
right-wing media venues for example
that monetize and capitalize on stoking
the fear
and resentment of
a white population that is witnessing a
changing america
and seeing uh demographic changes and
and
do everything they can to give people a
sense that
um their way of life is threatened and
that people are trying to take advantage
of them and we're seeing it
right now right where you would think
with all the public policy debates that
are taking place right now
that you know the republican party would
uh be
engaged in a significant debate about
how are we going to deal with the
economy and what are we going to do
about climate change and what are we
going to do about
lo and behold the single most uh
important issue to them apparently right
now is critical race theory
who knew that that was the threat to our
republic
man i got to tell you i i voted for
obama twice i
i don't regret things in life because i
think you learn things by past mistakes
but i would say it was a mistake
voting for that guy you can see the way
through his very calm cool demeanor
and the way that i'm sort of right about
everything because of the way i talk
about everything
that underneath it is actually a very
dangerous person
because first off he's saying that it's
right wing media that monetizes these
things now
the idea of that is just so on its face
ridiculous left-wing media is
absolutely everywhere pretty much
controls everything and we all know that
the culture war that is raging right now
is finally that a couple say right
leaning or conservative voices or
whatever you want to consider me
are pushing against the giant thing that
has been monetized
through corporations corporations love
black lives matter corporations love
pride month corporations love antifa and
all
of this gender nonsense and everything
else so the idea that it's right-wing
media monetizing on people's fears
is crazy it's actually left-wing media
doing it which we're going to get to in
the next story in just a second
left-wing media is monetizing on
everyone's fears of white supremacy
which doesn't even exist there are no
structures of white supremacy in the
united states there are no political
people show me someone in the united
states government who is a white
supremacist who literally wants
laws that are different for white people
these people don't exist these
so he's actually they're doing what they
do with everything which is a complete
180 lie you're taking what you do which
is racialize everything and you're
making it
seem that it's the scary right-wing
white people that are doing it
then he says well republicans should be
focused on the economy
or climate change not critical race
theory now why would barack obama
want to diminish the danger that is
critical race theory which in essence is
now the driving
force behind the democratic party it's
because he's obviously
for it and and wants you to take your
eye off the ball
and yes we should all be against
critical race theory and it is not
misguided on the part of republicans or
conservatives
to not want their children taught in
school that america is fundamentally
racist
that systemic racism is real that things
like being on time and hard work and
getting math
questions correct are tools of white
supremacy
you would want children to be taught
that their skin color doesn't matter as
opposed to is the thing that matters
most
so in some ways it is the most important
thing because it's the thing that's here
to destroy everything else critical race
theory is here to ultimately destroy the
economy right critical race theory
doesn't want an economy that runs on
capitalism and free markets
and and freedom of choice and all of
those things and human ingenuity it
wants
giant systems of socialism and marxism
these are obvious
things so to link these things together
i may think a lot of things about barack
obama but i don't think he's an idiot
it's fairly obvious why he wants
critical race theory
taught in school and it's and it's
pretty freaking dangerous
um so he's lying about what the media
does and he's lying about
actually what critical race theory is is
his point because otherwise
what is his point right is his point
that we should be teaching critical race
theory which if it is then then he's
been fully
unmasked as a marxist which that i guess
that would be news
right in a normal time it would be news
if the former president of the united
states
fully came out as a marxist or is he
he's trying to simply diminish it so
that it can keep squeaking its way
through
so i mean oh and also white america
voted for him
he's talking about white america white
america voted for you twice
barry yeah and nobody cared what your
first name sounded like or what your
last name sounded like
or nobody cared that your dad was from
kenya or any of those things i voted for
you twice
it had nothing to do i think with you
being black or anything else
right like i voted for you because i
thought you were better than the other
guys john mccain and mitt romney
in retrospect i think the country would
be a lot better off if either one of
them and romney's
i think romney's horrible now right
because romney's just a pet republican
well i can go on mse nbc and they'll pat
me on the head and give me a cookie
cookie like brian stelter yesterday um
anyway i think you guys see my point i
mean his implication
is that america is fundamentally racist
and these racist people are losing
control
and it's like barry the racist people
voted for you
this this meme of white supremacy is so
spectacularly
wrong and dishonest and that's a perfect
segue to our third story so you may
remember on the show yesterday
i talked about the idea of laundering
lies that this is in essence what the
media is doing so i was talking about it
yesterday
in the context of jen pasaki the white
house
press secretary on brian stelter's show
you know the most ironically named show
in the history of television reliable
sources and what
stelter was asking was in effect what
could we
what could we as the media do to help
the messaging
of the presidency more what could
journalists do better
and it was ideal laundering because you
would never ask that of the people
you're supposed to be holding to account
so they just launder their lies and then
it sort of seems like
news oh the press secretary was on with
stelter
and it's on cnn it kind of seems like
news but in effect they're just
laundering a lie well
i got a perfect perfect example of it to
show you right now so before i show you
the clip
this is msnbc and they did a segment
on a washington post op-ed by the
by a guy by the name of max boot and
he's just sort of a never trump
republican which again it's just one of
these pet republicans you'll never
defend
any sort of conservative idea but they
let you go on msnbc and they treat you
like a pet and you get your cookie and
you go home
and you never actually accomplish
anything or defend any of your purported
ideas or anything like that i would say
this is sort of like bill crystal or
david from these or the lincoln project
people these are just ineffectual
that sort of nobodies nobody likes them
except the msnbc people
that use them as pets well he wrote a
piece in washington post
called too many people are
underestimating the trump
threat so here you have a guy writing a
piece
in washington post about the trump
threat now that sounds very scary
then on msnbc they analyze this very
piece that he wrote and they bring in a
journalist
from the new york times her name is mara
gay
to analyze this trump threat now before
i show you the clip you may remember as
i said earlier
mara gay just a few weeks ago was
interviewing andrew yang
in the new york times and said that me
dave rubin that i
regularly host white supremacists i
tweeted at her many times asking her for
clarification on that of course she
did not respond we also gave away a
month free to anyone who signed up
uh at the reuben report community in
honor of marigay i think we used mara it
was code mara
uh at the time uh so i thank you for
that mara she also got the name of the
show wrong she called it the dave rubin
show
we couldn't get a retraction or a
correction or anything because these
people aren't journalists they're just
human jokes
that show up on these shows but anyway
uh
she then so you have a washington post
writer who writes an op-ed
then msnbc covers that very op-ed who's
written you know it's written in effect
by an activist
a democratic activist it's then covered
in
msnbc and they bring in a new york times
journalist
to analyze it and you're not going to
believe it this woman was on long island
and they had american flags
video long island this weekend visiting
a really
dear friend and i was really disturbed i
saw you know dozens and dozens of pickup
trucks with
uh you know explicatives against joe
biden
on the back of them trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know uh is also just
disturbing because essentially the
message was clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
i own this and so until we're ready to
have that conversation
this is going to continue i think she
means expletives not explicatives but i
don't want to be a white supremacist by
correcting anyone's english
um but look i come from long island one
of the
good things i think one of the things
that actually made me who i am the
reason that perhaps you watch this show
is that long island is actually a
wonderfully diverse place where
you're outside of new york city you know
about 45 minutes outside of new york
city so it's the suburbs
of the big city and what you got there
was so many people who were second and
third generation americans whose parents
you know grew up basically in queens and
brooklyn in tenement houses and small
apartments just like my grandparents
you know one bedroom six kids uh and
and then eventually through hard work in
the american dream they got
their families to be able to move out to
the suburbs my family is
literally an example of the american
dream and so many
people whether they were irish or
italian or jewish or black or hispanic
or whatever it is all did that on long
island long island's sort of the best
example
of what america could be in a certain
sense and then have that proximity
to the big city where the the further
generations who then
then were middle class could go and
follow their dreams
and some crazy kid from long island
could try to do stand-up comedy in new
york city
for years and then eventually do
something that led to something pretty
decent
in 2021 yeah this guy um it's a
beautiful place long island
anyway her fear first off that there
were people with trucks
with with uh auntie biden messages on
the but
the the trucks i suppose or the flags
first off i just don't believe that i
mean there may have been
one or two that she saw but like have
any of you anyone watching this
seen lots of trucks driving around like
can i say the f word
we don't want to get demonetized sue so
much escape screw
old joe biden have you seen that flag
have you seen that flag no
when trump was president everywhere you
went there were pictures of trump as a
nazi and crossing out his face and
giving him a mustache and all of those
things
but but further it's really the flag
part here that's disturbing hey i think
she's just mostly making this stuff up
but
she has what i think is and i don't mean
to make this about her
it doesn't it really doesn't matter
about her and i don't even care what she
said about me
but but the idea that a new york times
journalist goes on msnbc to comment on a
washington most story shows you how they
launder the lies
and that then she gets up there and she
fears the american flag
and and don't take my word for it listen
to what she's saying when she sees the
american flag
that somehow triggers a thought in her
mind about white supremacy and then you
can sort of link it back
to what obama just said that you know
these the white people are getting
nervous and that they
i don't know they pray to the american
flag to keep what they've lost like it's
just a bunch
of of self-serving myopic
drivel that really is what it is and
in some ways mara
you're the racist you're the racist
nobody cares what color you are i wish
you well in whatever it is that you're
doing right like that's great you work
at the new york times it's a crumbling
place of journalism and you're not a
very good journalist
but like great for you to have that job
that that's just fantastic so i don't
mean to make this about you
mara but the point is you're obsessed
with race
so it's do you think it's possible could
it be possible that people
i know this is crazy i'm gonna need a
little bit of a leash here people
do you think it's possible that
somewhere in america there are some
people who are proud
of the american flag and proud of the
constitution and the bill of rights and
this wonderful country that we've had
for 250 years that have give has given
more freedom
to more people than could have ever been
imaginable do you think there are some
people that are worried that that we're
losing
that not having anything to do with race
but that we're actually
trading in equality for equity we're
erasing our own history
and demolishing the things that freed
people
uh in the name of your crazed social
justice and it has nothing to do with
them being racist
it has them has everything to do with
them caring about freedom and liberty
and that kind of stuff
do you think that that's possible and
and the answer i suspect and mari you're
welcome to come on the show
to tell me this yourself but i suspect
her answer would be no because
they see everything in a racialized
world
but i can tell you this when i went to
donald trump rallies and i went to a few
here in crazy lefty california
in the heart of los angeles in beverly
hills bananas beverly hills
i saw american flags everywhere i saw
trump flags i saw all sorts of stuff i
saw gay flags
and everybody was really nice
and i didn't see any racist people so i
think it's possible that the american
flag stands for something other than
race
and that you're unfortunately you're in
some sort of requiem for a dream where
you see the american flag
and it makes you think that everyone's
racist not good uh and now this is a
little bit of a cheap shot but
you know it's youtube what am i gonna do
if you don't remember who mara gay is
well here she is uh
doing some math on msnbc with brian
williams and of course if you don't
remember brian williams he was the nbc
anchor he was once on nbc
nightly news the prime time anchor at 6
30 pm they caught him lying and his
punishment
was to have to host the show on msnbc
that's a beautiful thing
so she went on his show you may remember
this from a couple months back
but you see it as a possibility if he
wants to spend a billion bucks
beating this guy he could do it
absolutely
um somebody tweeted recently that um
actually with the money he spent he
could have given every american
a million when i
read it uh tonight on social media it
kind of all became clear
bloomberg spent 500 million on ads u.s
population 327
million uh don't tell us if you're ahead
of us on the math he could have given
each american
one million dollars and have had lunch
money left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way
of putting it it's true it's disturbing
it does
it does suggest you know what we're
talking about here which is there's too
much money in politics um
i'm sorry i know it's cheap but that
clip is just so
perfect because she completely makes up
nonsense he accepts the nonsense that
got by producers and directors i've got
two guys in this room
they do better fact checking god bless
you guys and you know what you both can
have chipotle for lunch today
um bloomberg spent 500 million
on the campaign that's what they were
saying there's 327 million americans
so i'm just math in my head it's
basically like i don't know you give
everybody a dollar fifty
not a million dollars each and they let
that run
and nobody corrected it
msnbc they've leaned so far forward they
actually fell into the bottomless pit
there you go
uh i enjoyed today's show i hope you
enjoyed today's show
part one of my interview with arielle
scarcella
is up in honor of lgbtq lmnop pride
month
she is a card carrying lesbian they get
a card when you become a lesbian they
give you a laminated card
uh and she left the left um so
what's it like for a lesbian to leave
the left
find out uh if you check our youtube
channel of course the full episode
is already up ad free at
rubinreport.locals.com
and that's it for me we're going to
scarf down some some chipotle and then
i'm headed
got about an hour drive i'm going to do
the babylon b podcast
and of course the babylon b is a satire
website which the new york times
i think has several times called like
right wing fake news media machine which
is just sort of hilarious
so be on the lookout for that oh and i
also did the uh
i did the ruthless podcast yesterday
with comfortably smug and his crew
if you're familiar on the twitter
machine and they just posted that this
morning so you can check that out
uh anyway some good stuff's happening
like we just got to keep pushing just
keep pushing keep pushing keep your head
on straight we're going to be all right
all right have a great day everybody